well you know what's crazy i feel like i
know you first of all one of my good
friends is robert longstreet who
yeah i know i see you love him who
doesn't love him you were you know
midnight mass together you were in
a hill house
yeah he's such a great i've known him
since like the 90s and
um he just talked so highly of you and
then i'm going to interview on monday
rahul kohli
see i mean isn't this funny such a small
world
it is and i think within that small
world there's a smaller world of people
who aren't [ __ ]
and like we can see each other across a
group and you know that because when you
like
people make fun of name droppers but
when you say to me i'm friends with
robert longstreet i know you're a good
guy
because robert longstreet isn't friends
with [ __ ] he's not and if they are
wrestles they're funny and charming and
worth it yeah rob's a lo he's a bit of a
loner does his own thing he goes his own
way
and i've always loved that about him but
he's but honestly i have to say this and
we won't get on because people are like
who's robert long street well look up
robert longstreet yeah watch him in some
of these you know
he's fantastic but like the guy i really
believe rob is a genius i do believe
he's a genius
yeah yeah he baffles me some of the
things he says i'm just like
how did that come out of someone's mouth
how do you come up with that [ __ ]
it's crazy
it's crazy so how did it all start for
you because i mean look at all the stuff
you've done and i'm a huge huge horror
fan
huge i interviewed your husband mike
flanagan who i think is one of the most
gifted directors writers out there
and i just
i felt like a kid in a candy store when
i'm you know when i was talking to him
because i'm just such a you know i have
an affinity for horror movies but you've
been in like all these horror movies or
shows the haunting of hill house and and
hush which you you co-wrote with mike
and midnight mass and oculus and the
fall of the house of ushers coming out
and ouija and gerald's game and it's
like oh i'm like holy [ __ ] you are
really you won the lottery when it comes
to this for horror fans you're in all
these do you do you love being called a
screen queen or is it something you're
like i'm not a swing queen you love it
you embrace it sure why not ride the
horse in front of you
what am i going to look down on the
people who got me where i am no and it's
also
for actors this is the top of everything
because you're not just like walking
into a
hospital operating room and going 10
cc's of saline with like a
calm face for 14 years you're like holy
[ __ ] my boyfriend's on fire they're
[ __ ] vampires i'm falling in love i'm
falling out of love i'm running through
the woods i'm covered in blood like for
people who love acting
horror genre is where it's at because
like every single one of those shows you
mentioned
all of those characters are stretched to
their breaking points and then they
break and if you don't want to play on
the biggest jungle gym like why are you
at the park
you